IN THE PUBLIC WELCOME TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE OF PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT. DO
THE CONTINUES HOME ORDER
REPRESSING FIZZLE DISTANCING
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM
THROUGHOUT THE STATE CAPITOL
BUILDING. SO ONLY ABLE TO HAVE
A LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE IN
THE HEARING IN PERSON WE'RE
ALSO REQUIRING THAT MASK THE
WORN AND PHYSICAL DISTANCING
THE MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TESTIFYING.
WEATHER HERE IN THE ROOM OR
REMOTE VIDEO CONFERENCE SITE.
DON'T HAVE A MASK CAN PROVIDE
ONE TO YOU. BEFORE WE BEGIN I'M
GOING TO TAKE A COUPLE OF
MINUTES TO GO THROUGH A FEW
OPTIONS AND PROTOCOLS
WITNESSES. FOR WOMEN'S
PARTICIPATION IN TESTIMONY
TODAY FOR THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM IN ROOM FOUR THREE SEVEN
THE STATE CAPITOL WERE MEETING
WE CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE A
MINIMAL NUMBER OF STAFF THE
PUBLIC AND THE MEDIA WE CAN
MAINTAIN SIX FOR THE SPACING.
IS ALSO STRICT FISCAL
DISCIPLINE PROTOCOLS FOR THE
PUBLIC TO INTERNALLY THE
CAPITAL AND FOR THOSE HERE IN
THIS ROOM. IF A MEMBER THIS
ROOM MUST TEST THE BILL UNLESS
YOU COME TO THE MICROPHONE. THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THE G. AND S.
THAT YOU NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. AFTER DONE SPEAKING
YOU CONNECTS THIS ROOM A RETURN
TO YOUR SEAT. BUT PLEASE MAKE
SURE THAT YOU'RE OBSERVING
PHYSICAL DISTANCING PROTOCOLS
LEAVE THE CAPITAL INCLUDING
LIMITING ELEVATOR USE. TWO TWO
PERFECT PEOPLE AT A TIME. FOR
WITNESSES VIA REMOTE VIDEO
STATION. MISSION TO BEING ABLE
TESTIFIED FROM INSIDE THE
HEARING ROOM WE MAY HAVE SOME
WITNESSES MAKE USE OF OUR
REMOTE VIDEO STATIONS. LOCATED
ON THE NORTH SIDE OF THE
CAPITOL GROUNDS IN A ROOM ONE
TWO SIX. THE STATE CAPITAL FOR
THIS HEARING. THOSE WITH THIS
WILL APPEAR ON THE SCREENS THAT
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE CAN
WATCH THE TESTIMONY LIVE. AND
ASK QUESTIONS IF WE HAVE ANY.
FOR THIS IS CALLING IN VIA
PHONE. WILL ALSO BE USING A
MODERATE TELEPHONE SERVICE THAT
WHAT THIS IS CAN USED TO
TESTIFY ON A BILL. THE COLOR
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN ONCE
AGAIN EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX
NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN
IN THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE
ONE. FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN. ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN. THE FINEST PHONE NUMBER
ON THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE NINE
YOUR TV OR COMPUTER SCREEN. FOR
CALLING IN PLEASE DO SELL IS
THE AUTHOR THE BILL BEGINS
PRESENTING THE BILL. THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO. BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE. DEPENDING
ON WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE A BILL. FOR CALLING IN
PLEASE LIMIT ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE SUCH AS MEANING YOUR TV.
LIVESTREAM BROADCASTS AND OTHER
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE
INTERRUPTION AND SOUND
DISTORTION. IF YOUR MAIN
WITNESS PROVIDING TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION ON A
BILL. REMAIN ON A LIVE LINE
YOU'LL NEED TO MEET YOURSELF
UNTIL YOU. ARE CALLED ON TO
SPEAK. EVERYONE IS ALL WHERE
THIS COMMITTEE X. WRITTEN.
THROUGH THE PER THE- LETTER
PORTAL. THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE
ENCOURAGES THOSE WHO HAVE ANY
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES TO USE
THIS OPTION. THANK YOU FOR
BEARING WITH US AS WE CONTINUE
IMPLEMENTING METHODS. TO SERVE
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. LAW
ALSO BEING MINDFUL AND
RESPECTFUL THE HEALTH CONCERNS
WE ALL FACE. WE'RE LIMITING
TESTIMONY FOR PRIME ME
WITNESSES IDENTIFIED BY THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE. TO TWO PEOPLE
IN SUPPORT. AND TWO PEOPLE
OPPOSITION. IT IS INDIVIDUALS
LEFT THREE MINUTES MAXIMUM TO
SPEAK. IF THEY ARE LESS THAN
TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES
REGARDLESS OF SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION. THE MAXIMUM. THREE
MINUTES STILL APPLIES. AT A
PRIMARY WITNESSES DONE EVERYONE
ELSE WOULD BE PERMITTED TO SAY
THEIR NAME. ORGANIZATION IF ANY
HAVE POSITION ON THE BILL. I'LL
BE ASKING THE PHONE OPERATOR TO
MOVE ON THE NEXT BICKER WHEN
YOUR TIME IS UP. THE SIMPSONS
EXPERIENCE A NUMBER OF
DISRUPTIONS TO COMMITTEE AND
FOR PROCEEDINGS IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS. SO THAT EVERYONE IS
CLEAR. CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS
AND DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE
IMPEDE THE ORDERLY CONDUCT THIS
HEARING IS PROHIBITED. SUCH
CONDCT MAY INCLUDE. REMOVING A
MASK AND REFUSING TO PUT IT
BACK ON IF YOU'RE TESTIFYING.
IN PERSON OR VIA REMOTE VIDEO
STATION OR ON THE CAPITOL
GROUNDS. TALKING OR MAKING LOUD
NOISES FROM THE AUDIENCE.
UTTERING LOUD THREATENING OR
ABUSIVE LANGUAGE. SPEAKING
LONGER THAN THE ALLOTTED TIME.
EXTENDED DISCUSSION OF MATTERS
NOT RELATED TO THE BILL BEING
DISCUSSED BY THE COMMITTEE AT
THE TIME AND OTHER DISRUPTIVE
ACTS. TO DRESS INTO SEPARATE
CONDUCT I WILL TAKE THE
FOLLOWING STEPS. IF SOMEONE
DISRUPT OUR HEARING PROCESS I
WOULD RECKON THE STOP AND WARN
THEM THAT CONTINUED DISRUPTIONS
MAY RESULT REMOVAL. FROM
PARTICIPATING IN THIS HEARING.
ALSO DOCUMENT ON THE RECORD THE
INDIVIDUAL INVOLVED IN THE
NATURE THE DECEPTIVE CONDUCT.
MAY TEMPORARILY RECESSED THE
HEARING. IF THE CONDUCT DOES
NOT STOP I REQUEST THE
ASSISTANCE THE SERGEANTS
REMOVING INDIVIDUAL FROM THE
HEARING INCLUDING ESCORTING THE
INDIVIDUAL FROM THE CAPITOL
BUILDING IF THEY'RE PHYSICALLY
PRESENT. THE IN ADVANCE FOR
YOUR COP. FOR BEFORE BEGAN WHEN
ESTABLISH A QUORUM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM COOPER
PRESENT WHO WERE PRESENT VOEPEL.
THEN CALDERON. CALDERON PRESS
CERVANTES COOLEY. COOLEY
PRESENT- DON. ALTHOUGH PRESENT
THEY ARE TO PERFORM. GOT A
QUORUM. SO WE'RE NOT WE'RE
GOING TO THE NEXT ITEM ON THE
AGENDA STARTING WITH. AB NINETY
FOUR. MISTER JONES SAWYER.
MEMBERS OF THE BILL WHEN YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU AND GOOD
AFTERNOON AND MEMBERS- I WOULD
LIKE TO START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND I WANT
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF
AND THE CHAIR BECAUSE I BELIEVE
THIS WILL. PROVIDE AT LEAST THE
CCPOA MEMBERS SAW A BACKSTOP
THE TO VOTE WERE NEGOTIATED
RIGHT NOW SO THAT THEIR MEMBERS
WILL HAVE SOME CONFIDENCE DATA
MANAGEMENT WILL COME AGAINST
THEM OR OR USED AS A WEAPONIZED
WHAT I'M TRYING TO DO AS FAR AS
MENTAL HEALTH SIDE I APPRECIATE
THE AID THE AMENDMENT SAID. AND
WE WILL BE ACCEPTING THANK YOU.
AB NINETY FOUR. OUR WILL WILL.
REQUIRES REQUIRE PROVIDE
PROTOCOLS SO EVERY CAR OFFICER.
HAS OPPORTUNITY RECEIVER YEARLY
MENTAL HEALTH EVALUATION AND BE
PROVIDED INFORMATIONAL
RESOURCES THAT CAN VOLUNTARY
THAT THEY CAN VOLUNTARILY
ACCESS. UNDER EXISTING LAW ALL
PEACE OFFICERS MONDAY BUT
UNDERGO A PRE EMPLOYMENT.
MENTAL HEALTH SCREENING TO
ENSURE THAT THEY ARE FREE OF
ANY CONDITIONS THAT WOULD
NEGATIVELY IMPACT ABILITY TO
PERFORM ESSENTIAL JOB DUTIES.
HOWEVER DESPITE REGULAR
EXPOSURE TO VIOLENCE. AND M.
ONE IN EVERY THREE OFFICERS
EXPERIENCE A SYMPTOM OF
POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS DISORDER.
THERE'S NOT. AN OBLIGATION TO
THESE SAME INDIVIDUALS TO
RECEIVE A FOLLOW UP AT ANY
TIME. WHEN THE SUICIDE RATES OF
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS ARE 39%
HIGHER THAN THE GENERAL
POPULATION- WE MUST DO
SOMETHING. THE CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS ARE RESPONDING THAT
THE REPORTING THAT THEY WANT TO
LEARN HOW TO COPE WITH PTSD.
BUT FEARFUL OF REPERCUSSIONS
FROM THE DEPARTMENT. IT IS
CLEAR. THAT THE CURRENT SYSTEM
IS NOT WORKING. WE NEED TO
ADDRESS THE- ABOUT THE K. OF
THE VALUE. AND THE POTENTIAL
FOR NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES BY
MANAGEMENT THEREFORE IN
ADDITION TO THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS SOLIDIFYING THE
CONFIDENTIALITY OF THESE EXAMS
I AM COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH.
ALL STAKEHOLDERS SO THAT WE MAY
FIND A SOLUTION AS WORKABLE FOR
ALL THOSE IMPACTED. A. B.
NINETY FOUR IS A MAJOR STEP IN
BREAKING DOWN THE TOXIC CULTURE
PRESENT IN OUR PRISONS AND THE
STIGMATIZING MENTAL HEALTH.
I'VE HAD MY FIRST MEETING WITH
CCPO WAIT WITH EXTREMELY
PRODUCTIVE. THEY COME TO ME
WITH SOME POSSIBLE AMENDMENTS-
THEIR BOARD WILL BE MEETING
WITH THEIR WITH THEIR UNION.
ALSO THE REUNION OF PRESIDENT
WHO HAVE BEEN MEETING WITH THE
CLIENTS DALY TO KIND OF GIVE ME
AN IDEA OF WHAT THEY WOULD LIKE
AND THE AMENDMENTS MOVING
FORWARD IF IT GETS OUT OF THIS.
COMMITTEE AND I'M COMMITTED TO
REALLY MAKING THIS A CCPOA BILL
AS WE MOVE FORWARD. AND
HOPEFULLY ONE DAY WILL BE ON
THE OTHER SIDE. ON THE SENATE
SIDE YOU'LL SEE CCPOA SITTING
NEXT TO ME AS WE MOVE FORWARD
WITHOUT MAKING THE LIFE WITHIN.
AND NO DISRESPECT TO MR COOPER
AND ONE OF THE TOUGHEST BEATS.
YOU. COULD WORK IN IN
CALIFORNIA.SO MEMBERS ARE. ASK
FOR YOUR AYE BUT- THANK MISTER
JONES SAWYER. ORDER NOW MOVED
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE OF GOT- TO SUPPORT THE
FIRST IS JOSE MORELLO. THIS
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE SYSTEM COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS JOSE PIRELA MOST
RECENTLY I SERVED AS THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER MARIN COUNTY UNTIL MY
RETIREMENT IN MARCH I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTEEN NINETY FOUR. AB NINETY
FOUR IS A WELL THOUGHT OUT
PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT
PROACTIVELY SUPPORT PRISON
GUARDS AND THOSE INCARCERATED
IN STATE PRISONS FILE SHARING
THE PRISON GUARDS ARE DOING
THEIR JOB WITH A STABLE
MINDSET. SOME OF THE SUPPORT
NEEDED WHEN GUARDS FONG THE
STRESS OF THE WORK OVERWHELMING.
HAVING SERVED AS A DEPUTY
ALTERNATE PUBLIC DEFENDER
INSTEAD. I HADN'T MANY CASES
ARE HANDLED KIDS ARISE OUT OF
THE DOCUMENTS PRISON. WHILE
THERE I LEARNED FIRSTHAND OF
THIS IN DOOR PRISON. AND HOW
SUCH LEAD TO COMFORT. WITH
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS AND
THE VIOLIN THAT ENSUED. OTHER
THAN ONE OF X. HIMSELF TO
INJURY- TO DEAL WITH THE STRESS
LITERALLY WORKED OUT SO MUCH
PEOPLE MUST FROM. STRUCTURE IF
YOU INJURED IN. IN ANOTHER IN
OF THE GOT WE ALL HAVE BY WITH
FOR STILL THE IDENTITY OF
DEFENDER AND PROCEEDED CREATE
CREEK CARDS AND WE'RE CONSUMER
BILLS THE GUARD PLAY THE STORE.
IN A SAID INSTANCE PUBLIC
POLITICALLY CORD TO DIE OF A
HEART. AT A YOUNG. THE FUNDS
AND YOU IN THE CHRISTIAN TOLD
ME OF THE STRESS WHICH TOO MUCH
FOR TO BEAR. IN A DAY AS PUBLIC
THE OF MY COUNTY I. ATTORNEYS
LINCOLN BOARD CAN OF SAN
QUENTIN STATE PRISON COMPLAINTS
OF COURSE AND FORCE WORKING
PERCENT TO JURORS IN CASES.
WORKING THE MOVE IN AFFECT
BECAUSE THE STAFF AND BEING
CARSON TO EQUAL YOUR TIME.
TRAGICALLY WE SAW INTENSE.
ADDITION ALL THOSE AT SAN
QUENTIN TESTED POSITIVE AND
LIVED OR DIED DUE AT ALL A
STRETCH THE HOURS AND WORKING
CONDITIONS ARE OFTEN IGNORED
THE ONE DEVELOPED AS MUCH AS
MORE RESPONSE TO STRESS. THAT
OFTEN MANIFEST SIMPLY TALLIED
FOURTEEN IMAGE AND EVEN FALLING
AMONG PRISON STAFF ARE YOU OF
ONE INDIVIDUAL WHO QUIT BEING A
PRISON GUARD BECAUSE OTHER
GUARDS THOUGHT THAT HE WAS NOT
TELLING THEIR BLUE LINE. IT WAS
MORE THAN THEY WERE GOING TO
SET HIM UP WITH AN ASSIGNMENT
TO ESCORT OF VIOLENT INMATE
CANNOT PROVIDE BACK UP WHEN THE
VIOLENCE ENSUED DISCARD UP THE
MESSAGING RESIGNED. STRESSED
DAILY CONTACT WITH HUNDREDS OF
ACCULTURATED INDIVIDUALS AND
APPEALING POSSIBILITY OF BODILY
HARM PUTS BOTH THE INCARCERATED
IN A CORRECTIONAL OFFICER AT
HIGHER LEVELS OF POSTTRAUMATIC
STRESS DISORDER SUBSTANCE ABUSE
AND MENTAL HEALTH BREAKDOWN. AB
NINETY FOUR ENSURES THE HUMANE
TREATMENT- AND SAFETY OF THOSE
WHO ARE INCARCERATED AND
PROTECTS THE SAFETY OF ALL WHO
WORK AND WORK OUT IN CALIFORNIA
STATE PRISON. I APPLAUD MEMBER
AND CHAIR OF THE STATE OF THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMISSION JONES
SAWYER WAS COURAGE TO INTRODUCE
THIS BILL. IT OFTEN TAKES
OUTSIDE ENCOURAGEMENT TO CREATE
A MEDICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
RESPONSE I ENCOURAGE PASSAGE OF
THIS LEGISLATION TO CREATE A
WOKE CULTURE OF HUMAN COMMITTEE
TREATMENT STATE PRISONS NOT
JUST FOR THE INCARCERATED.
BEFORE ALL WHO SUPERVISE
MORNING AND EVENING LINESH
GENERAL POPULATION
ADMINISTRATIVE SEGREGATION
ASSIGNMENTS IN LIVE MOMENT TO
MOMENT WITH THE REALITY THAT
EVERYTHING COULD GO UP IN A
VIOLENT STORM. I ASK YOU TO
VOTE. ON THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANYMORE PRIME
WITNESSES SUPPORT. THIS WILL
THIS ISN'T ROOM. I DON'T ANY.
WHEN THIS IS V. REMOTE VIDEO.
IT APPEARS ARE OUT ARE NONE
NEXT WITNESS IS ON THE PHONE
OPERATOR. WITH THE OPERATOR WHO
AS IT MIGHT BE. AT THAT POINT-
IN SUPPORT OF AB NINETY FOUR
FEET PRESS ONE THAT THE ROW.
THAT COMMAND AGAIN. ONE SEVEN
ZERO. AND MISTER CHAIRED
APPEARS THAT WE HAVE NO
COMMENTS COMING THROUGH AT THE
TIME OKAY THANK YOU THAT'S A
LITTLE UP BUT THIS IS IN
OPPOSITION AND OUR PRIMARY
WITNESSES. IN OPPOSITION- I
SHOW TO MATTHEW EASILY IN
MEMORY A DRONE. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MATTHEW
EASILY REPRESENT CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION. IN RECENT YEARS
NEGOTIATION IS MADE OFFICER
MIDDLE HELP THE PRIORITY
TOGETHER WITH OUR BENEFIT TRUST
FUND WE'VE HAD SEVERAL
LEGISLATIVE ATTEMPTS INSTITUTED
STANDARDIZED DEPARTMENT LIKE
YOUR SUPPORT PROGRAM.
SUCCESSFUL IN THOSE LEGISLATIVE
EFFORTS WE'RE NOW FINDING
MAKING SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS
WORKING DIRECTLY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION I WILL SOON HAVE
A FULLY FUNCTIONAL PROGRAM UP
AND RUNNING. WE ALSO AT THAT
THE DEPARTMENT WITH THE RECENT
LAUNCH OF THE CORTICAL AT WHICH
IS A MOBILE APPLICATION THAT.
CONFIDENTIALLY DIRECT DOCTORS
TO MIDDLE BOTH RESOURCES WHEN
IN NEED. A MAJOR FOCUS OF THE
ASSOCIATION'S EFFORTS HAVE ALSO
BEEN TO SIGNAL THE CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS THAT KNOWLEDGE IN
MENTAL HEALTH DIFFICULTIES IN
SEEKING HELP. WILL NOT AND
SHOULD NOT PUT YOUR CAREER WITH.
OVERCOMING THE STIGMA
ASSOCIATEDWITH ADMITTING
CHALLENGES WITH YOUR MENTAL
HEALTH HAS BEEN AN UP HILL
BATTLE. THE WAR FINALLY
CHIPPING AWAY AT THAT BARRIER
TO HEALING. UNFORTUNATELY WE DO
STILL OPPOSED THE MANDATORY
ANNUAL EVALUATION LANGUAGE
CONTAINED IN THE BILL'S CURRENT
FORM. AS WE FEEL IT WILL LIKELY
LEAD TO PERCEPTIONS THAT
INFORMATION COULD IMPACT
OFFICERS CAREERS AND
BACKTRACKED ON SOME OF THE
PROGRESS WE'VE MADE. REGARDING
THE WILLINGNESS OF OFFICERS TO
SEEK HELP. WE DO HOWEVER
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS NOT THE
AUTHOR'S INTENT INTENTION- AND
APPRECIATE HIS COMMENT THAT
MADE DURING HIS OPENING
STATEMENT. MAKING ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES AVAILABLE THAT
SUPPLEMENT UP YOUR SUPPORT
PROGRAM AND PROVIDING
INCENTIVES TO ENCOURAGE
OFFICERS YOU CAN RECEIVE THE
ACTUAL HELP NECESSARY. TO HEAL
WOULD BETTER PROMOTE BUY IN
FROM AUTHORS AS WILLING
PARTICIPANTS IN THE MIDDLE
HEALTH JOURNEY. THAT THAT BE
GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN BY THE OP
THERE PRIOR TO THE PUBLIC
SAFETY HEARING AS WELL AS THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENT APPROACH
YOUR TODAY. THEY MAKE THE
FINANCIAL AGREEMENT THE BILL
AND DEFINITELY MOVE UP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION. THE FACT THAT
THE AUTHORS BEEN WILLING. TO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE'S
IMPROVEMENT THEN THE
CONFIDENTIALITY PROVISION THE
HUGE STEP IN CLEARLY
DEMONSTRATED THE DARK IN THE
DRESS ARE CONCERNED. THE AUTHOR
HAS REACHED OUT TO THE
ASSOCIATION THAT THE PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED. THAT HAVE COMMITTED
TO WORKING TOGETHER TO ACHIEVE
REAL PROGRESS. IN THE REALM OF
OPTIMAL HEALTH. YOU'RE VERY
OPERATE AT VERY UP. ABOUT WHAT
WE CAN ACCOMPLISH TOGETHER AND
LOOK FORWARD TO OUR CONTINUING
CONVERSATIONS MOVING FORWARD.
WE HELP THE EIGHTY NINETY FOUR
MOVE FORWARD TODAY WITH AUTHORS
COMMITMENT TO ADDRESS THEIR
REMAINING CONCERNS. AND I'D
ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR
AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR WORK THAT THEY DID ON
THAT COMMITMENT. THAT YOU'RE
YOU'RE DILIGENT EFFORTS HAVE.
DEFINITELY GOT A LONG WAY
TOWARDS ENSURING OFFICERS ARE
PROTECTED- AND THAT PROMOTING
AN ENVIRONMENT WHERE OFFICERS
ARE COMFORTABLE WITH THE
KNOWLEDGE ISSUES THEY MAY BE
HAVING. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE TODAY. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. AFTER ENSURE IN MEMBER
NAOMI TO JOHN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL PEACE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION BENEFIT
TRUST FUND ALSO IN RESPECT TO
OPPOSITION TO THE CURRENT
VERSION OF EIGHTEEN NINETY FOUR
FIFTY THREE PM AWAY BENEFIT
TRUST FUND PROVIDE HEALTH
WELFARE AND DEATH BENEFITS
ACTIVE AND RETIRED CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS ACROSS THE STATE.
TOGETHER WITH THE DPA AWAY WE
RECOGNIZE THE NEED TO
PRIORITIZE THE WELL BEING OF
OUR CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS AND
THEIR FAMILIES IN RECENT YEARS
THE CCPOA BENEFIT TRUST FUND
HAS DEVELOPED AN ONGOING MENTAL
HEALTH AWARENESS PROGRAM IN
WHICH WE HOPE STATEWIDE EVENTS
TO BOLSTER OFFICER WELLNESS AND
ENCOURAGE THE USE OF AVAILABLE
SUPPORT SERVICES WE ALSO OFFER
FREE ACCESS TO THE AYE WRITE
THIS OP WHICH CONNECTS OUR
OFFICERS TO TRAIN PROFESSIONALS
WHO CAN PROVIDE HELP.
ADDITIONALLY WE CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE DPR AND
PHYSICALLY THE OFFICE OF
EMPLOYEE HEALTH AND WELLNESS
ITHIN THE DEPARTMENT TO
AUGMENT PROGRAMS AND POLICIES
THAT CAN HELP MITIGATE THE
INHERENT STRUCTURED A
CORRECTIONAL WORK WE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY AGREE THAT MORE
NEEDS TO BE DONE TO PROMOTE
CORRECTIONAL HEALTH AND
WELLNESS ASPECTS WE WOULD LIKE
TO THANK THE AUTHOR IN THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR ATTENTION
TO THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE.
FURTHER WE GREATLY APPRECIATE
AMENDMENT TAKEN TO IMPROVE THE
BILL THE AUTHOR HAS REACHED OUT
AND EXPRESSED INTEREST IN
WORKING TOGETHER TO FIND REAL
SOLUTIONS FOR THE MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL OFFICER AND WE'RE
HOPEFUL WE CAN ACHIEVE A
POSITIVE. OUTCOME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU A STILL CONTINUE ON
WITH THIS IS NOT WITH. ANYWAY
THIS IS IN THE HEARING ROOM. I
SEE NONE. OF THIS IS REMOTE
STATE. WE DON'T HAVE ANY NEXT
WILL MOVE THE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE
OPERATOR. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR COMMENT IN OPPOSITION
TO A B. NINETY FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. THAT
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE SEVEN ZERO.
AND WE HAVE NO COMMENTS COMING
THROUGH AT THE TIME. THANK YOU
OPERATOR. OKAY I'M- WE GOT A
BILL MOVED INTO SECOND
MEDICALLY. THANK YOU. THE BILL
FOR. AND- PRINT THANK YOU FOR
WORKING WITH PEOPLE- I
APPRECIATE THANK YOU THANK
REFER JOHNSON BRING THIS BILL
FOR THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH
A CORRECTIONAL PEACE OFFICERS
IMAGES TAKEN I WANNA SAY I
THINK IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
BILL. AND I ACTUALLY AM
GRATIFIED TO HEAR THIS SORT OF
ALIGNS AS MR EASILY SEVERAL.
INITIATIVES ALREADY UNDERWAY
WITH PEACE OFFICERS. ARE WITH
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS. I THINK
THAT THIS ISSUE OF. MENTAL
HEALTH IS SUCH A TERRIBLE TITLE
TO HANG ON THINGS. ARE AND SO I
HOPE THE OPPONENTS ARE LISTEN
THE FOLKS ARE TALKING YOU'RE
LISTENING I PERSONALLY THINK
THIS BILL IS ABOUT. THE FACT
THAT YOU CAN TAKE THE OFFICER
OUT OF THE PRISON. AND THE
QUESTION IS CAN YOU TAKE THE
PRESIDEN OF THE OFFICER. THEY
NEED TO GO HOME THEY NEED TO BE
HUSBANDS THEY NEED TO BE.
THAT'S ARE THEY HAVE FRIENDS
THAT THEY ASSOCIATE WITH. THEY
ARE MODELS OF A CAREER WHICH IS
VERY IMPORTANT N CALIFORNIA
AND SAW HOW THEY THEIR ABILITY
CANNOT LEAVE THE PRISON AND
LEAVE THE PRESENT BEHIND AS
THEY HEAD HOME IS ACTUALLY VERY
IMPORTANT TO OUR ABILITY TO
SUSTAIN OUR PRISONS AND RECRUIT
THE TRACK PEOPLE. SO I JUST
THINK THIS IS A IT MAY BE A
DIFFICULT TOPIC BUT ACTUALLY I
THINK IT'S ONE THAT. WE OUGHT
TO BE BACKING THEM UP IN THIS
CONVERSATION I THINK THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL DOES. I THINK
THE WORK THEY PERFORM IS VERY
DIFFICULT. ARM AND HONESTLY I
THINK FRAME THE WAY I DESCRIBE
IT. CAN YOU. WHEN YOU TAKE THE
PRESENTS THE CORRECTIONAL
OFFICER OUT OF THE PRISON CAN
YOU TAKE THE PRESIDING OFFICER
WHEN THEY GO HOME. I THINK MOST
CALIFORNIA'S ACTUALLY BELIEVE
THAT'S A HUGE ISSUE. AND NOT.
FOR THEIR FAILINGS. BUT JUST
LIKE THEY'RE DOING IS VERY
IMPORTANT PUBLIC WORK AND THE
STRESSES AND STRAINS OF WHAT
THEY DEAL WITH ON THE JOB.
COULD EASILY FOLLOW THEM HOME.
AND COMPLICATE THEIR PERSONAL
LIVES AND- YOU KNOW BECAUSE
YOUR HUSBANDS FATHER'S- OF.
WIVES THEY HAVE THESE OTHER
OBLIGATIONS SO. I REALLY FEEL
THIS IS AN ASPECT OF TRYING TO
HAVE THE BACK. OF OUR
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS. IT IS TO
NOT LEAVE THEM ALONE WITH THE
STRESSES AND STRAINS OF THEIR
JOB. IS TO TRY TO COME IN AND
PROVIDE A WAY OF SUPPORT. ANNA
I SEEM TO QUOTE THIS OFTEN BUT
I REMEMBER. A SERMON I ONCE
HEARD WHEN I WAS. SEVENTEEN AND
THE SERVER WAS ON THE SEVEN
LAST WORDS OF THE CHURCH. AS
ACCESS INTERESTING TOPIC WHAT
THE HECK WOULD BE THE SEVEN
LAST WORDS OF THE CHURCH THE
SEVEN LAST WORDS BEFORE THE
TRUTH BECAME IRRELEVANT. TURNED
OUT THE SEVEN LAST WORDS WERE
WE'VE NEVER TRIED IT THAT WAY
BEFORE. SO I SORT OF THINK THE
WAY WE KEEP AHEAD OF ISSUES AS
WE DO TRY DO IDEAS WE LOOK AT
NEW IDEAS. I THINK THIS IS A
VERY IMPORTANT ONE AND I THINK
IT'S AS GOOD AS FOLLOWS. HOW DO
WE HELP OUR CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS LEAVE THE WORK BEHIND
WHEN THEY CALL HOME- AND-
FULFILL ALL THEIR ROLES WITHOUT
DRAGGING THAT AROUND. SO I'M
VERY APPRECIATIVE YOU BRING
FORTH THE BILL. I'D LIKE TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR IF YOU
HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY. AND I
JUST. COMMEND YOU FOR THE
CONVERSATION REMARKED UPON WITH
THE CCPO AND THEIR TRUST FUND
AND OTHER INTERESTED PARTIES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MR COOLEY
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
TO THE COMMITTEE. YOU'VE GOT A
MOTION BY MISTER COOLEY SECOND
MR VOEPEL- MEDITECH TRICKING
PICKEREL CALL PLEASE. THE
MOTION IS THE PAST AS AMENDED
AND BE RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
COOPER HI COOPER II VOEPEL
RIGHT VOEPEL OUR CALDERON.
FATHER OWNED I CERVANTES COOLEY
AYE COOLEY AYE O'DONNELL FIGURE
TO. A FULL PARDON FOR VOTE
PHONE CALLS OKAY THE BILL CYCLE
MR JONES SAWYER I WANNA THANK
YOU FOR TAKING THE AMENDMENTS I
THINK WE WORK TOGETHER AND GET
THINGS DONE AND IT MAKES THE
BETTER AND MUCH STRONGER BILL
ALONG ONE SIDE I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COOPERATION YOU'RE WELCOME
AND- WE MAY SEE SOMETHING THAT
WE DON'T. OFTEN SEE PEOPLE WITH.
TWO DIFFERENT PHILOSOPHIES
COMING TOGETHER. TO SOLVE ONE
PROBLEM AND WE NEED MORE THAN
SEVENTY. THANK YOU. FOR WE'RE
NOW MOVES ON TO THE NEXT ITEM
ON THE AGENDA. WILL BE AB ONE
ZERO FIVE WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDEN MEMBERS OF THE BILL WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU TO
SHARE OUR BROUGHT MY GOOD LUCK
HERE THAT'S AMAZING TENNIS
HOLDEN. GOOD THINGS HAPPEN
WHATEVER IT REGULATORY. MISTER
MEMBERS TODAY I'M PRESENTING AB
ONE OH FIVE A BILL THAT
IDENTIFIES AND REFORMS
PROCESSES THAT HINDER UPWARD
MOBILITY FOR PEOPLE OF COLOR IN
THE CIVIL SERVICE SYSTEM.
MEMBERS OVER THE PAST FEW
MONTHS THE SACRAMENTO BEE HAS
PUBLISHED A SERIES OF LETTERS
WRITTEN ON BEHALF OF AFRICAN
AMERICAN EMPLOYEES WORKING AT
ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS THE
CALIFORNIA AIR FOR AIR
RESOURCES BOARD. ARE CALIFORNIA
PRISON SYSTEM. AND THE OFFICE
OF STATE PUBLISHING ALL OF
THESE INSTANCES HAVE A COMMON
DENOMINATOR THERE ARE BARRIERS
TO UPWARD MOBILITY AND
INCLUSION. LAST YEAR GOVERNORNEWSOM TOOK A BOLD STEP FORWARD
BY SIGNING MY BILL AB NINE
SEVEN NINE WHICH IT REQUIRES
EACH PUB PUBLICLY HELD.
CORPORATION WHOSE PRINCIPAL
EXECUTIVE OFFICES ARE LOCATED
IN CALIFORNIA. TO HAVE A
MINIMUM NUMBER OF DIRECTORS
FROM UNDERREPRESENTED
COMMUNITIES ON ITS BOARD OF
DIRECTORS. THE GOAL IS PLAIN
AND SIMPLE WE NEED TO INCREASE
UPWARD MOBILITY OPPORTUNITIES
FOR PEOPLE OF COLOR. THIS WAS A
PRAISE WORTHY STEP FOR
EMPLOYEES IN THE PRIVATE
SECTOR. HOWEVER THERE ARE
PERPETUAL BARRIERS TO UPWARD
MOBILITY THAT EXIST IN PUBLIC
SECTOR CIVIL SERVICE SYSTEM. IT
IS IN THE SPIRIT. THAT I PUT
FORWARD A NUMBER OF CIVIL
SERVICE REFORMS THAT ARE
REFLECTED IN AB ONE OH FIVE.
FOR STARTERS AB ONE OH FIVE
CALLS FOR DIVERSITY IN ALL
STATE BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS
THAT HAVE VOLUNTEERS. AS YOU
KNOW THE CONSTITUTION DOES NOT
ALLOW PREFERENTIAL TREATMENT
BASED ON RACE GENDER OR SEXUAL
ORIENTATION AND THE OPERATION
OF PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT EDUCATION
AND CONTRACTING. THEREFORE THE
LEGISLATURE CAN NOT REQUIRED
DIVERSITY. REGARDING BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS THAT ARE SOLELY
COMPRISED OF STATE EMPLOYEES
HOWEVER THE LEGISLATURE IS
ALLOWED TO REQUIRE DIVERSITY ON
BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS WERE THE
BOARD MEMBER OR COMMISSIONER IS
A VOLUNTEER. AB ONE OH FIVE
SEEKS TO DIVERSIFY THE
POSITIONS OF VOLUNTEER BOARD
MEMBERS AND COMMISSIONERS AS
VACANCIES OCCUR. FURTHER THE
BILL PROVIDES THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN RESOURCES
MAY DEVELOP MODEL UPWARD
MOBILITY GOALS TO INCLUDE RACE
GENDER AND LGBT Q. AS FACTORS
TO THE EXTENT PERMISSIBLE UNDER
STATE AND FEDERAL EQUAL
PROTECTION LAWS. THE INCLUSION
OF THESE FACTORS ARE SIMPLY
MEANT TO HIGHLIGHT THE NEED FOR
DIVERSITY. I'M AWARE OF THE
PROVISIONS OF PROP TWO OH NINE
AND WANT TO ENSURE THAT THIS
BILL DOES NOT VIOLATE THE
CONSTITUTION. COLLEAGUES OVER
THE PAST SEVEN YEARS THE CAL H.
R. WORKFORCE ANALYSIS AND
CENSUS REPORT. INDICATES
CONSISTENTLY THAT OVER 60% OF
THOSE IN MANAGEMENT POSITIONS
ARE WHITE MALE AND FEMALE. WELL
THE DEMOGRAPHIC FOR THIS GROUP
HAS HOVERED AROUND THIRTY FIVE
PERCENT. ON THE OTHER END OF
THE SPECTRUM 60% OF THOSE CIVIL
SERVICE EMPLOYEES MAKING FORTY
THOUSAND OR LESS ARE PEOPLE OF
COLOR. THESE ARE THE SAME
MANAGERS THAT ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR ADVERTISING RECRUITING AND
HIRING CIVIL SERVICE EMPLOYEES.
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR IMPLICIT
BIAS SHOULD BE CONSIDERED.
THEREFORE AB ONE OH FIVE
REQUIRES THAT THE STATE
PERSONNEL BOARD ESTABLISH A
PROCESS THAT INCLUDES DIVERSITY
AND BEST PRACTICES IN EACH
ASPECT OF THE DESIGN
ANNOUNCEMENT ADMINISTRATION OF
EXAM EXAMINATIONS FOR THE STAB
US MET OF EMPLOYMENT LISTS. A
DIVERSE PERSPECTIVE IN ALL
ASPECTS OF THE HIRING PROCESS
PROVIDES FOR A MORE DIVERSE
WORKFORCE AND BETTER OUTCOMES.
FINALLY AB ONE OH FIVE REQUIRES
THAT CALLIE CHAR SUBMIT WITHIN
ITS ANNUAL WORKFORCE ANALYSIS A
CONSENSUS REPORT. ALL OF THE
ADVERSE ACTIONS TAKEN BY
DEPARTMENTS AGAINST EMPLOYEES.
IT CALLS FOR THE REPORT TO
INCLUDE THE TYPE OF ADVERSE
ACTION ETHNICITY GENDER AND
SEXUAL ORIENTATION IF
AVAILABLE. THE GOAL IS TO SEE
IF THERE ARE PATTERNS OF
DISCRIMINATION IN THE
DEPARTMENTS. CLOSE AND I WANT
TO THANK THE CONSULTANT. AND
THE ADMINISTRATION FOR WORKING
WITH MY OFFICE THERE ARE SOME
AREAS THAT WE WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK ON SHOULD THIS BILL MOVED
TO APPROPRIATIONS SUCH AS
SHIFTING COMPLIANCE FROM S. B.
B. TO CALAIS CHAR. AND THE
ASSISTANCE OF COLLEGE ARE WITH
THE PARCHMENTS THAT FAIL TO
MEET UPWARD MOBILITY GOALS.
AFTER A RECENT MEETING WITH
ADMINISTRATION OUR OFFICE HAS A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF THE
DUTIES AND RESPONSIBILITIES OF
S. S. P. B. THANK COLLEGE ARE
AND WILL WORK TO ADDRESS THOSE
CONCERNS. WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS SABRINA LINDSEY A CO
FOUNDER CEO COALITION OF BLACK
EMPLOYEES AND EMMANUEL I'M A
FORK CO FOUNDER DIRECTOR ABOUT
REACH COALITION OF BLACK
EMPLOYEES. OF THIS BILL HAS THE
SUPPORT OF THE CALIFORNIA Y.
STATE CONFERENCE IN DOUBLE ACP
THE AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY
EMPOWERMENT COUNCIL CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR JUST AND
EQUITABLE CALIFORNIA. AND THE
NATIONAL ASSEMBLY OF AMERICAN
SLAVERY DESCENDANTS LOS ANGELES
WITHOUT I ASK FOR YOUR I.
PHONE. THANK YOU MR HOLDEN
WE'RE NOT ALLOWED TO PRIMARY
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT OUR
WITNESS FIRST UPPER SABRINA
LINSEY. MY NAME IS SABRINA
LATELY. AT CAN YOU HEAR ME I'M
SORRY YES LONG CLEAR. ON THANK
YOU MY NAME IS SABRINA LINDSEY
AND I AM A CURRENT EMPLOYEE OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS- THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS IS
THE THIRD LARGEST LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY. IN THE
UNITED STATES BEHIND THE US
CUSTOMS BORDER PROTECTION WHICH
IS AN ARM OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOME SECURITY AND THE NEW YORK
POLICE DEPARTMENT. EIGHTY THREE
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS ARE SWORN
LAW ENFORCEMENT IN OFFICERS
WITH PEACE OFFICER POWER. CDC
AND OTHER GOVERNMENT AGENCIES
ARE INCREASINGLY USING TERMS
LIKE EQUITY DIVERSITY AND
RACIAL JUSTICE WITHOUT
RECOGNIZING THE IMPORTANCE OF
HAVING A WORKFORCE THAT
REFLECTS THESE PRINCIPLES. WE
HOPE WE ARE SPEAKING UP BECAUSE
WE BELIEVE THAT BLACK EMPLOYEES
MUST PLAY A CRITICAL ROLE IF
THESE AGENCIES TO THE BELIEVE
IN THE PURSUIT OF EQUITY
DIVERSITY AND RACIAL JUSTICE.
NOW WHAT AB ONE OH FIVE WE
BELIEVE IT'S THE MOMENT OF
ACCOUNTABILITY. AB T. R. AND
OTHER STATE AGENCIES MUST
COMMIT TO CREATE A WORK FOR
FORCE MADE UP OF DIVERSITY. AND
UNIQUE INDIVIDUALS WHO
CONTRIBUTE TO OUR
ORGANIZATIONAL SUCCESS.
CELEBRATING DIVERSITY VALUING
R. ONE ANOTHER AND RECOGNIZING
THAT OUR STUDENTS IS NOT IN
SPITE OF THE DIVERSE ATTRIBUTES
OF OUR WORKFORCE BUT BECAUSE OF
OUR DIVERSITY. THE TYING AND
MOMENTS ARE HERE TO DEFINE AND
EFFECT REVOLUTIONARY CULTURAL
CHANGE FOR INCLUSION
PROMOTIONAL OPPORTUNITIES AND
EQUITY ACROSS THE BOARD FOR CDC
ARE AN ALLSTATE AGENCY I THANK
YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN FOR
ALLOWING US TO- AB IN PROVIDE
OUR SHARED STORIES AND KOBE WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AB
ONE OH FIVE AND WE BELIEVE THIS
IS A PROGRESSIVE STEP FORWARD
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OUR NEXT
WITNESS IS A MANUAL AND A FOUR.
YEAH CAN EVERYONE HEAR ME. YES
WE CAN HEAR YOU A LOT. YES GO
AHEAD GREAT- ARE WE CAN'T
BREATHE THE DEMOCRATS SEVEN IS
ON OUR NECK WE ARE HEARTBROKEN
I BELIEVE IN WITH WORRY AND
EMOTIONALLY DISTRAUGHT EVEN
WHEN WE RIDE TO BE EXCELLENT IN
OUR CAREERS OPPORTUNITIES ARE
CONTINUOUSLY REPRESS. I'M
CONSTANTLY PATH OVER FOR
PROMOTION NO I HAVE THE COPY.
ALIVE MANAGER IN A Y. ANALYST.
NOW HIRED ON PROBATION WHILE
DRIVING A STATEMENT THE CAR
WERE PULLED OVER FOR DRUNK
DRIVING THE MANAGER WITH THE
DRIVER WAS CITED ARRESTED FOR
DO A LOT. THE ANALYST WAS NOT
FIGHT IT THE MANAGER AND STAFF
WERE ALLOWED TO COMPLETE THE
PROBATION. I WILL QUICKLY
PROMOTED. ANOTHER EXAMPLE I DO
NOT SEE ENOUGH OF MY FACE MY
VOICE IS NOT MY CURRENT DESPITE.
THE HIGH LEVEL LEADERSHIP WHEN
MY STAY DEPARTMENT DO YOU SEE A-
SET TO. AND TEN. SEVEN
ACTIVATION I. IN EXPECTED ALL
THE MARIN THE DEMO PROFILE OF
THE POPULATION MISTER.
EXECUTIVE THREE HAVE ANYWAY AT
THE TOP. THEY HAVE TO BE TO
JUST LOOK AT THE LEAD TEAM.
GALLAGHER PROPER. A SYSTEM.
THAT VERY. AND DIVERSITY. WE
TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY. HOW WE-
OUR LIVES IF THAT ARE CURRENTLY
OUT OF THE AS REPRESENTATION OF
BLACKS THE EMPLOYEE. WE ARE THE
COSTA BLACK AND- ADVOCATING FOR
RESPECT AND JUSTICE STATE.
WITHIN A COUPLE OF APARTMENT.
FOR MILLENNIALS GENERATION X.'S
AND BIG MOMENTS INTO
EXPERIENCES RIGHT TO CONCLUDE
THIRTY YEARS WORKING IN THE
STATE. MICHAEL SOME OF THE
MURDERS OF AHMAD BURKE VERY
VALID TELE JOSH LAW. AND
PROTESTS OVER SUBJECT ENOUGH.
WITHOUT SO THINGS THE END OF.
WE COULD NOT LONGER STOP TOUGH
FIVE AND WATCH HARD TO GET
HUMANITY IS A FIVE AND I
WORKPLACE. REGULAR ENJOY
INVOLVED THERE TO TALK. WE USE
OUR TO THE NOT. A CO OF BLACK
SO ACTION BY MEETING INSURANCE
NEEDS CHANCE WITH THE PREVIOUS
YEAR EXPERIENCE THAT LEAD US.
OFF COURSE. OUR CONCERNS WERE
DISMISSED. BY THE LEAST TO
OTHER TO OUR ELECTED. ARE A
MEETING WITH THE FAMILY MAY
HOLDEN. THE COALITION OF BLACK
EMPLOYEES WHAT THE TO
COLLABORATE WITH THE FAMILY
MORE MEMBER HOLDEN JEAN. RECORD
AND PUT THAT PROPOSAL. TO BE IN
COURT INTO THE. ONE FIVE. THE
ALBUM ACT UP TO A- TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. AB ONE OF FIVE A
PROGRESS THAT THE FACT OF.
POCKET REFORM. GREAT
ACCOUNTABILITY TRADE AFFECT OUR-
AS YOU CONTINUE TO ONGOING WORK
AGAIN JUST AND- RACISM. A
COALITION OF BLACK INFO AT. SIX
UP. OF AB ONE OF FIVE. THANK
YOU AND HAVE A GOOD DAY. THANK
YOU. THIS WHAT THE WITNESSES
THE HEARING ANYONE IS
SUPPORTING HER IN WEST NINE.
WE'LL DOING THIS IN SUPPORT VIA
REMOTE STATION. SINGLE TV
SCREEN THIS WILL WITNESSES IN
PHONE OPERATOR. FOR COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT OF AB ONE OH FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
THAT COMMAND AGAIN ONE THEN.
ZERO AND WE HAVE NO COMMENTS
COMING THROUGH AT THE TIME
THANK YOU REMOVE UNDER WHEN
THIS IS IN OPPOSITION I HAVE NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES SO MOVED TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IN THE
HEARING ROOM- SAYING NONE- THE
WITNESSES OPPOSITION ON THE
REMOTE VIDEO STATION. OUT THERE
ARE NONE SO MOVED OVER THIS IS
ON THE PHONE IN OPPOSITION
OPERATOR. FOR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION TO AB ONE OH FIVE
THE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO THAT
COMMAND AGAIN ONE ZERO. AND WE
HAVE NO COMMENTS COMING THROUGH
AT THE- THANK YOU LET'S BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE MANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE AS- MR HOLDEN THE
MOTION. OKAY WE GOT A MOTION BY
MISTER COOLEY SECOND BY MISS-
CALDERON- MR HOLDEN PROJECT
MAKE A CLOSING STATEMENT ON
YOUR BILL. ALTHOUGH WE SEE
THIS- I REALLY DO APPRECIATE
THE COMMITTEE'S CONSULTANT WORK
WITH OUR STAFF AND CERTAINLY TO
YOU MISTER CHAIR TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS WAS A AS THOUGHTFUL
AND WELL. EVALUATED A PROPOSAL
AS WE COULD PUT FORWARD OF THE
CONVERSATIONS ACTUALLY BEGAN
AROUND THIS BILL AT THE END OF
LAST YEAR AND- SO I JUST WANT
THE RECORD TO REFLECT CLEANLY
AND CLEARLY JUST HOW MUCH I
APPRECIATE. THE CHAIR AND-
COMMITTEE STAFF WORKING WITH US
ON THIS AS WELL AS THE
ADMINISTRATION SO WE WOULD
UNDERSTAND HOW BEST TO PUT
SOMETHING FORWARD THAT WAS.
ASSISTING DOUBLE AND THE
CORRECT WAY TO DO IT. THANK YOU
MITCHELL OF WORKING WITH STAFF
AND WE REALLY APPRECIATE IT AND
I THINK IN THE END IT IT MADE
IT A BETTER BILL- I WOULD LIKE
TO ALSO GET AS A CO AUTHOR ON
YOUR BILL NIXON PORTEN AND I.
COMMEND YOU FOR BRINGING
FORWARD THANK YOU SIR- SO WE'VE
GOT A- FIRST THE SECOND A THE
CHAIRS RECKLEZZ AN ALLY- MEDIC
SECRETARY. MENTAL PLEASE. THE
MOTION IS THE PAST AND BE RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS COOPER HI COOPER
I VOEPEL NOT. VOEPEL NOT
VOTING. FOR THEIR OWN. FOLLOW I.
CERVANTES CERVANTES I COOLEY.
FIVE COOLEY I O. THERE ARE TWO.
THE BILL HAS FOUR VOTES WILL
PLACE AN ON CALL. K. E. BILLS
LOCAL MR HOLDEN THANK YOU. I'M
GONNA TAKE THIS TO MY NEXT
COMMITTED. THE REQUESTED. FOR
AND WHAT WHAT UP FOR THE RECORD
THAT MR IS THAT IS- EVERCORE
SILVA THERE BILL I. AB EIGHT
NINETY OF THIS CERVANTES. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES I THINK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHT NINETY TODAY HI THIS
IS A BILL THAT WILL ENSURE
TRANSPARENCY AND PROMOTE THE
INCLUSION OF WOMEN AND MINORITY
MONEY MANAGERS IN THE ASSET
MANAGEMENT INDUSTRY. THIS BILL
WOULD REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT
SYSTEM IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
TEACHERS RETIREMENT SYSTEM TO
PROVIDE A REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON THE UTILIZATION
OF EMERGING AND DIVERSE MONEY
MANAGERS. CALPERS AND CAL STIRS
HAVE A COMBINED ASSET OF OVER
SEVEN HUNDRED BILLION BUT A
RELATIVELY LOW RATE OF
PARTICIPATION OF EMERGING AND
DIVERSE MANAGERS WHEN COMPARED
TO OTHER STATE PENSION SYSTEMS.
IN THE WORLD OF BUSINESS AND
ENTREPRENEURSHIP FEW THINGS ARE
MORE DETERMINATIVE OF YOUR
ABILITY TO SUCCEED IN THE
ABILITY. OF AVAILABILITY OF
INVESTMENT CAPITAL. BUT THE
HARD TRUTH IS THAT FOR WOMEN
AND PEOPLE OF COLOR.
PARTICULARLY ACCESS IN THE
CAPITAL OUR COMPANIES NEED TO
FLOURISH AND GROW IS DIFFICULT.
IT IS CLEAR THAT SYSTEMIC
INEQUITIES EXIST AND HOW THE
SYSTEM SELECT MANAGERS TO
INVEST THE CAPITAL THAT THEY
OVERSEE. DUE TO THE LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY THE FIRMS THAT ARE
OFTEN EXCLUDED FROM
PARTICIPATION ARE WOMEN AND
MINORITY FIRMS. THE CYCLE FOR
PERJURY PERPETUATES THE
HISTORIC NEGLECT AND A LACK OF
RESOURCES FOR HISTORICALLY
DISENFRANCHISED COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA. IN CALIFORNIA
CANNOT HAVE A SURE SUCCESS
WITHOUT SHARED OPPORTUNITY. IN
ORDER TO ADDRESSES SYSTEMIC
INEQUITIES THE LEGISLATURE WILL
NEED TO ACTORS NEED ACCURATE
INFORMATION ON HOW CALPERS AND
CAL STIRS. DISBURSAL CAPITAL TO
WOMEN AND MINORITY MANAGERS
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL TODAY IS SELANDER
BROKE CEO THE NEW AMERICAN
ALLIANCE WHO'S A SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU FOR NEXT
MOVES TO PROMISES SUPPORT US
MISS BROOKS. I THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS TO LAUNCH
FERNANDES BROOKS AND I'M THE
CEO OF THE NEW AMERICA ALLIANCE
OR AN EIGHT THE ANY IS A
NATIONAL NONPROFIT ASSOCIATION
OF LATINO BUSINESS LEADERS
DEDICATED TO ADVANCING THE
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT OF THE
AMERICAN LATINO COMMUNITY OUR
GOAL IS TO INCREASE THE
AVAILABILITY OF INVESTMENT
CAPITAL TO WOMEN AND MINORITY
OWNED FIRMS AND TO PROMOTE
DIVERSE LEADERSHIP AND
ENTREPRENEURSHIP CORPORATE
AMERICA AND PUBLIC SERVICE. THE
AVAILABILITY OF CAPITAL MEANS
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A
COMMUNITY THAT CAN BILL BOTH
INDIVIDUAL AND COMMUNITY WEALTH
THROUGH FORCING BUSINESSES AND
JOB OPPORTUNITIES AND THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT STAGNATES THAT
WE HAD HIGHER LEVELS. OF
POVERTY AND THE LACK OF
OPPORTUNITY. ENABLE THE THIS AB
EIGHT. IS AN IMPORTANT MEASURE
THAT WILL. AN ENHANCE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
HAVING CALPERS AND CAL STIRS
REPORT ON HOW THEY DEPLOY THEIR
INVESTMENT ASETS WHICH WAS
MENTIONED IN APPROXIMATELY
SEVEN HUNDRED BILLION COMBINED.
TRANSPARENCY IS THE FIRST STEP
PRIOR TO AN AA. TEN OF MY
FIFTEEN YEARS OF THE PORTFOLIO
MANAGER WITHIN THE CHARACTERS
INVESTMENT BRANCH WE SPEND
REPORTING DIRECTLY TO THE CHIEF
INVESTMENT OFFICER. I HELPED
CREATE AND LED AND MANAGE TO
FIND INVESTMENTS WITH WOMEN AND
MINORITY MANAGERS THE LAST FIVE
YEARS I MANAGED A GLOBAL
PORTFOLIO. OF MEN AND WOMEN
WORKING IN THE PENSION PLANS
ARE GOOD INTELLIGENT PEOPLE AND
THEY DO THEIR VERY BEST. TO DO.
THE WORK THE VERY. BEST THEY
CAN HOWEVER. THEY WORK IN A
CULTURE WHERE LARGE INVESTMENT
FIRMS ARE FAVORED. AND IN
INVESTMENTS THE LARGE
INVESTMENT FIRMS ARE
TRADITIONALLY MALE AND WHITE.
AND IT MADE ME BELIEVE THAT IT
IS A TO DO SHE EVERY
RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURE ALL
OPPORTUNITIES ARE VETTED TO
ENABLE THE SELECTION OF THE
BEST INVESTMENT FIRM FOR THIS
STRATEGY CAN GENERATE THE BEST
RETURN PRETENSIONERS. WOMEN AND
PEOPLE OF COLOR ARE ALMOST 70%
OF THE POPULATION IN ACCORDING
TO A TWO TWENTY NINETEEN NIGHT
COMBINATION STUDY. ONLY ONE
POINT 3% OF THE SIXTY NINE
TRILLION ASSET MANAGEMENT
INDUSTRY IS MANAGED BY WOMEN
AND MINORITY OWNED FIRMS. THIS
IS NOT A QUESTION OF ASKING
CALPERS OUR CULTURES TO ENTRUST
THEIR ATHLETES WITH LOW
PERFORMING MANAGERS BUT IT IS
ABOUT ASKING THEM TO IDENTIFY
PUBLIC FUNDS ARE MANAGED AND
INVESTED WITH HIGH PERFORMING
WOMEN AND MINORITIES BANISTERS.
IT IS ABOUT ACCOUNTABILITY.
ULTIMATELY MOVING THE NEEDLE ON
THIS ISSUE REQUIRES ACTIVE
LEGISLATIVE ENGAGEMENT THIS
WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH THAT DATA
YOU'LL NEED TO ACCURATELY
ASSESS HOW THE FUNDS ARE.
PERFORMING ON DIVERSITY. SIMPLE
BUT CREWS FIRST. THANK AND I'M
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE. THANK
YOU OUR NEXT PRIMARY WITNESSES
SUPPORT IS JIM PARK. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JIM PARK
CEO OF SUFFICIENT REASON
AMERICAN INVESTMENT MANAGERS
ALSO KNOWN AS ANY WE ARE
NINETY INTRODUCED BY
ASSEMBLYWOMAN CERVANTES. THIS
BILL IS AN IMPORTANT MEASURE
THAT WILL REINSTATE AND ENHANCE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
AND HOW CALPERS AND CAL STIRS
DEPLOY THEIR RESPECTIVE
INVESTMENT ASSETS THAT OUR
COUNTRY BOTH FROM THE AFTERMATH
OF THE DEVASTATING PANDEMIC.
AND THE SOCIAL INJUSTICE WE
WITNESSED LAST YEAR ENDED SURE
CONDUCT INDUSTRY AND GOVERNMENT
LEADERS MUST WORK TOGETHER TO
EMPOWER DIVERSE COMMUNITIES AND
CREATE EXPANDEDECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES FOR EVERYONE WE
BELIEVE AB EIGHT NINETY THERE'S
A CRITICAL BUILDING BLOCKS TO
CREATING A MORE EQUITABLE
ECONOMIC SOCIETY FOR EVERYONE.
FOUNDED IN TWO THOUSAND SETS
INTO THE NATIONAL NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION DEDICATED TO
PROMOTING DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION OF ASIAN AMERICANS
AND PACIFIC ISLANDERS IN THE
FIELD OF INVESTMENT MANAGERS WE
HAVE SEEN FIRST HAND THE POWER
OF DIVERSITY IN THE WORK WE DO
WEDDING AND THE NORMA'S BENEFIT
INCLUDES THE POLICIES CREEK FOR
INVESTMENT INDUSTRY AT LARGE.
SINCE SINCE YEAR TWO THOUSAND
ASIAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY
PACIFIC ISLANDER POPULATIONS IN
THE U. S. HAS GROWN FASTER THAN
ANY OTHER POPULATION IN THE
COUNTRY CURRENTLY REPRESENTING
ABOUT 6% OF THE OVERALL U. S.
POPULATION- BUT IT 15% OF
CALIFORNIA POPULATION TODAY-
THE PERCEPTION THAT THE
COMMUNITY HAS ACHIEVED BROUGHT
SUCCESS IN EVERY ASPECT OF OUR
SOCIETY. IS FAR FROM REALITY IN
THE FACT THAT OUR COMMUNITY
CONTINUES TO FACE SIGNIFICANT
DISCRIMINATION EXPERIENCED HATE
CRIMES AND EXPERIENCED ECONOMIC
HARDSHIP IN CERTAIN SEGMENTS
LAST YOUR NAME RELEASED A STUDY
WHICH FOUND THAT LET YOU WHAT
HAPPENED MANAGER TERMS WITH
MAJORITY ASIAN AMERICAN
OWNERSHIP REPRESENT ONLY THREE
POINT 5% OF THE INDUSTRY TOTAL.
THESE TERMS ARE TYPICALLY MUCH
SMALLER THAN THE END OF. THE
INDUSTRY AVERAGE AND OVERALL
ALL. AMERICAN FONG MANAGE JOBS
POINTS THAT PERCENT OF ASSETS
UNDER MANAGEMENT. DESPITE THEIR
PER. MEETING OR EXCEEDING AND
GOT. THIS PERFORMANCE ARE TO
WITH THE WE- SALON SINAN. ABOUT
THE NIGHT FROM BASE WHICH FILE
THAT A- DRAMATIC UNDER
REPRESENTS OF. BUT OTHER- FIRM
IN INDIA DEAL DESPITE THE FACT
THAT THESE BONDS DID NOT SEE
ANY DROP IN PERFORMANCE WE
SUPPORT MORE ALLOCATION TO MORE
WOMEN. OR MINORITY OWNED FIRMS
TALKING. FOX FARMS DO NOT FIX
SIX ARE NOT EXTRA FROM EMERGING
PROGRAM THERE IS OFTEN A PUT ON
A FALSE PERCEPTION IN THE
INVESTMENT MANAGEMENT INDUSTRY
THAT IF YOU GUYS DO NOT VERY
SIGNIFICANT INSTITUTIONAL
OBSTACLES. AS A RESULT API
OWNED FIRMS ARE OFTEN
OVERLOOKED FOR THESE PROGRAMS
NATIONWIDE BURKE SOME FORTY SIX
PUBLIC PENSION FUNDS CALPERS
MCALLISTER DURING THE LARGEST
PARTICIPATING IN THE EMERGING
MANAGERS PROGRAM. FOCUSED ON
PUBLIC MARKET INVESTMENT BUT
ONLY REPRESENTS TWENTY THREE
BILLION IN TOTAL ASSET
ALLOCATION. HOWEVER THE TOTAL
STOCK WOULD BE PROGRAM STILL
REPRESENT A VERY SMALL PORTION
OF THE OVERALL INSTITUTIONAL
INVESTORS TOTAL ASSETS AND OF
THE HUNDRED FORTY SIX UNIQUE
MANAGERS PARTICIPATING IN THESE
EMERGING MANAGERS PROGRAM
STRUCK THE- COUNTRY LAST YEAR.
AND FOUND THAT ONLY SEVEN ARE
SEVEN ASIAN AMERICAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER ALL. BUT LACK
OF ACCESS TO THESE TYPES OF
PROGRAMS HINDER OUR COLLECTIVE
ABILITY TO PROVIDE INVESTMENT
CAPITAL FOR WOMEN AND MINORITY
OWNED BUSINESSES. CALIFORNIA
CANNOT BENEFIT FROM THE FULL
POWER OF DIVERSITY WITHOUT
PROVIDING SHARED OPPORTUNITY
AND THIS CANNOT BE DONE
WITHOUT- WITHOUT THAT JUST
CAN'T BE DONE. WITHOUT
SACRIFICING ANY RETURNS AB
EIGHT NINETY IT'S AN IMPORTANT
FIRST STEP IN PROVIDING
POLICYMAKERS WITH THE DATA THEY
NEED TO UNDERSTAND HOW THE
BILL'S ALLOCATION DECISIONS
ARE. ARE ENHANCING THE LIVES OF
ALL COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TODAY AND TO SUPPORT.
THIS IMPORTANT MATTER. THANK
YOU NET MOVE ON THE WAY. AND
THE IN THE HEARING ROOM I SEE
NONE- MOVING TO WITNESSES VIA
REMOTE VIDEO STATION. OUR
SCREEN IS BLANK ALSO MOVED WHEN
THIS IS ON THE PHONE OPERATOR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT
NINETY PLEASE PRESS ONE IF THAN
EVER. I COMMAND AGAIN OF. ONE
ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO COMMENT
COMING FOR AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU- THE WITNESSES OPPOSITION I
HAVE KNOWN FOR PRIMARY
WITNESSES I'LL LOOK FOR
WITNESSES IN THE HEARING ROOM
IN OPPOSITION SEEING NONE. WILL
MOVED WITNESSES VIA REMOTE
VIDEO STATION OUR SCREEN STILL
BLANK SO MOVED WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE
OPERATOR. FOUR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION TO IT A. B. EIGHT
NINETY PLEASE PRESS ONE SEVEN
ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN. ONE
ZERO. WE HAVE NO COMMENTS
COMING THROUGH AT THE TIME
THANK YOU WELCOME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS SEEING NONE. MR VOEPEL.
YES ON A COUPLE COMMENTS I'VE
SPENT QUITE A FEW YEARS IN THE
FINANCIAL SERVICES INDUSTRY.
AND I UNDERSTAND THE INTENT OF
THIS BILL AND WHERE YOU WANT TO
GO WITH IT TRUST ME I GET IT
BUT I'M NOT ANALYTICAL. IN SOME
OF THE- PROBLEMS I HAVE WITH
THIS BILL. IS THERE IS NO
DEFINITION. FOR THE CALPERS AND
CAL STIRS REPORTS THERE'S NO
GUIDELINES NO DEFINITIONS AND
BASICALLY THEY CAN MAKE UP
THEIR OWN GUIDELINES AND
DEFINITIONS AND- THEY CAN
DETERMINE WHETHER IT'S A ONE
PAGE REPORT. FOUR HUNDRED PAGE
REPORT BASICALLY FROM WHAT I'M
READING HERE- ALSO. CALPERS AND
CAL STIRS EVEN THOUGH THERE
PUBLIC A PUBLIC. INVESTMENT
SLASH RETIREMENT FUND. ALL THE
INVESTMENT MANAGERS IN MY
THIRTY NINE YEARS EXPERIENCE IN
THE INDUSTRY. INVESTMENT
MANAGERS HAVE THEIR FAVORITE
BROKERS THEIR FAVORITE HEDGE
FUND GUYS THEIR FAVORITE
EVERYTHING SO- PROBABLY THIS
BILL WILL NOT GET TO WHERE YOU
WANNA GO- AND THEN. LAST WAS
WHAT YOU WANT IS INVESTMENT
MANAGERS THAT GET YOU THE
HIGHEST RATE OF RETURN- AND
THAT WOULD BE COMPLETELY IN THE
OPPOSITE OF WHAT THIS BILL IS
TRYING TO DO SO I JUST WANTED
TO THE AUTHOR DID KNOW WHERE
I'M COMING FROM IT IT JUST
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO ME THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MR COOLEY.
ELEVEN FOR INTERNET OPERATIVE
IN MY USED IN THIS BUILDING
NINETEEN THERE'S SOME BREAKFAST
MEDICAL CARE I'M THE TO BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL I'M THE
BILL. AND USED OF. THERE WAS A
JOINT LETTER COMMITTEE ON
PENSION INVESTMENTS- BY MY
BOSS. AND AMONG OTHER THINGS IT
PASSED AND SENT TO THE VOTERS
AC SIXTY THREE WHICH BECAME
PROP TWENTY ONE. WHICH IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR HAVING
FAILED IN EIGHTY TWO PASSED AND
PUT. IN PLACE FOR CALIFORNIA'S
INVESTMENT SYSTEM THE FOOD NEXT
COURT RULE. WHAT SETS UP THE
ROLE OF INVESTORS. AND IT'S
SORT OF IRONIC THAT OF. IN THE
NINETEEN EIGHTIES TO JOINT
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC
PENSION FUND INVESTMENTS WHICH
AFFECTED A REVOLUTION WHERE
PENSION FUNDS OPERATED WAS.
ADVISED BY A WOMAN MARCY A
RENOVATED FOR ECONOMICS OF WHO
WAS THE TOUCHSTONE FOR A LOT OF
THEIR POLICIES THAT CAME OUT OF
THAT BODY IN FIVE YEARS WAS
TWENTY TWO BILLS OF THAT HAD A
MAJOR IMPACT ON OUR PENSION
SYSTEM SO. ON HI I BELIEVE THE
EFFECT OF THE PROJECT PER RULE
WILL. SUPPORTERS MOVING FORWARD
I THINK IT IMPOSES AN
OBLIGATION ON THE PRINTER
SYSTEMS I ALSO THINK. THEIR
FOCUS THIS BILL RATE OF RETURN
AND NOT NECESSARILY IN WRITING
VOLUMINOUS REPORTS THE
LEGISLATURE I THINK IN REPORTED
OUT TO US WE WILL FIND THE
SWEET SPOT FOR WHAT THE
LAWMAKERS WANT. OF OUR POWER OF
OVERSIGHT GOING TO HELP US DO
THAT BUT I THINK THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT POSITION I THINK ARM
IS A PRECEPT OF INVESTMENT YOU
WANT TO DIVERSIFY YOUR RISKS
AND I WOULD ACTUALLY SAY IN
HAVING A BROADER ARRAY OF
PERSONALITIES INVOLVED
INVESTMENT DECISIONS. ALL THAT
IS A FORM OF DIVERSIFICATION
IT'S ALLOWS US TO HAVE OTHER
PEOPLE LOOKING IN THE MARKET
TURNING OVER THE ROCKS IT MAKES
SENSE TO THEM AND FINDING
POTENTIAL VALUE FOR THEIR
CALPERS AND CAL STIRS SO I AM
PLEASED TO SUPPORT THIS BILL OF
FINGERPRINT FOR. SO WE WILL
FIRST BY MR IS OUR SECOND.
SECOND MR O'DONNELL- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CERVANTES LIKE TO CLOSE
IN YOUR BILL YES AND THANK YOU
FOR THE COMMENTS- FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS YES TO THE
LARGEST INSTITUTIONAL INVESTORS
IN THE WORLD YOU KNOW THESE TWO
PENSION FUNDS SET THE STANDARD-
OF HOW OTHER INSTITUTIONS
INVEST. I THEIR CAPITAL AND
AGAIN YOU KNOW THIS IS A
TRANSPARENCY BILL THAT WILL
PROVIDE THE LEGISLATURE THE
DATA NECESSARY TO UNDERSTAND
HOW THESE PENSION FUNDS I DO
APPROACH DIVERSITY AND WITH
THAT I'D LIKE LAST MINUTE.
THANK YOU. A MAN SECRETARY TO
TAKE ROLL CALL. THE MOTION IS
PATH AND BE RIVER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
COOPER HI COOPER AYE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL NO CALDERON. CALDERON
AYE CERVANTES AYE CERVANTES AYE
AYE COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE
O'DONNELL. O'DONNELL ICR TO.
THE BILL HAS SIX. THE THING
THAT WILL HAVE. FIVE WHAT'S UP
WITH A BALLOON COUGH. FIVE TWO
ONE. THANK YOU. THIS TO BILLS
REMIND SOMEONE TO OVER TO MY BY
CHAIR MISTER VOEPEL. VERY WELL
MR CHAIR IS HERE TO PRESENT A.
B. SIX FIFTY SEVEN MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YES I CAN'T TAKE CREDIT
FOR THESE ACTUALLY ROB BONTA IS
BILLS BUT THESE ARE ATTORNEY
GENERAL MALCOLM I'M IN A PINCH
HIT FOR MONEY. A THE CREDIT TO
MR BONTA- THE STATE CIVIL
SERVICE ACT ESTABLISHES
STANDARDS FOR THE USE OF
PERSONAL SERVICES CONTRACTS BY
STATE AGENCIES WOULD PRESCRIBE
POSITION CONDITIONS ARE MET.
THESE THE PERSONAL SERVICES
CONTRACTS SHOULD BE C.
SPARINGLY WHEN THEY'RE FUNDED
FULL TIME POSITIONS NOT BEING
FILLED. THIS IS ESPECIALLY TRUE
WHEN THOSE VACANCIES ARE HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS SUCH AS
PHYSICIANS SURGEONS.
PSYCHOLOGIST AND DENTIST. WITH
PROFESSIONALS A CONTRACTOR
CONSISTENTLY SOMETIMES THAT DO
BECAUSE WE'RE IMPACTING THE
QUALITY OF CARE TO PATIENTS. SB
SIX FIVE SEVEN PROVIDE
PROTECTIONS AND TRANSPARENCY.
TO THE STATE'S HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AND PROFESSIONALS BY
PROHIBITING A STATE AGENCY FROM
ENTERING INTO A CONTRACT. THE
PROFESSIONAL FOR A PERIOD OF
MORE THAN THREE HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE CONSECUTIVE DAYS OFF FOR A
PERIOD OF THREE SIXTY FIVE
KNOCKED AT THE DAYS. INN A
TWENTY FOUR MONTH PERIOD. THE
FINAL PROFESSIONAL TO INCLUDE
AMONG OTHERS IF THE VISION.
SURGEON DENTIST A CLINICAL
PSYCHOLOGIST EMPLOYER TO
EMPLOYEE UNIONS CERTAIN
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS WITH ME
TODAY IS WITNESSES ARE IN
SUPPORT OF OUR DOCTORS TOUR BUS
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNION OF
AMERICAN PHYSICIANS AND
DENTISTS. ASK ME LOCAL TWO ZERO
SIX AND DOCTOR RYAN KIM NEED OF
AMERICANS THIS AND THE DENTIST
BOARD OF DIRECTORS. OPERATOR
PLEASE BRING ON THE WITNESSES.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE DR STUART
BUT THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNION
OF AMERICAN POSITION TO DENNIS
STAFF B. TWO OH SIX I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB SIX FIFTY
SEVEN THIS BILL WHEN SIGNED
INTO LAW WILL PER IMPROVE THE
HIRING TRUCK PROSPECTS OF STATE
DOCTORS DENTISTS PSYCHOLOGISTS-
AND PHARMACIST. IT WILL HELP
REDUCE THE CIVIL SERVICE WITH
BACON C. RATE AND SAVE MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS FOR CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS FOR DECADES THE STATE
IS CONTRACTED OUT BARGAINING
UNIT SIXTEEN VACANCIES TO
EXPENSIVE PRIVATE REGISTRIES
MEANWHILE OUR CIVIL SERVICE
WORKFORCE HAS DWINDLED DOWN FOR
A VARIETY OF REASONS RELATED TO
THE DIVERSION OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THAT WERE ALLOCATED TO
CIVIL SERVICE POSITIONS. BUT
THEY'RE BEING USED TO PAY
CONTRACTORS THE RESULT
PRINCIPAL SERVICES BEEN MINIMAL
SALARY INCREASES MANY MAKE
RECRUITING EFFORTS BY THE STATE
AND SIGNIFICANT SIGN UP BONUSES
SB SIX FIFTY SEVEN IS A STEP TO
CORRECT THIS IMBALANCE ALTHOUGH
THE STATE CLAIMS THAT THEY
PREFERRED CIVIL SERVICE DOCTORS%
OVER CONTRACTORS ITS BEHAVIOR
INDICATES OTHERWISE. WHETHER
NEGOTIATING WITH OUR WITH US
FOR OUR AMMO USER MEETING WITH
YOU A PD AND ARE CONTRACTING
OUT COMMITTEES THERE'S ONLY
LISTSERV A STATE TO OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION BONUSES ADDITIONAL
APPOINTMENTS FOR CIVIL SERVANTS
ARE ROUTINELY REJECTED. NO
WONDER THAT THE CDC ARE
PSYCHIATRY VACANCY RATE IS
NEARLY 50% OF THE VACANCY RATE
AT SOME PSH DISABILITIES YEARS.
80% ALEX HELLO USES IT
EMERGENCE POWER UNDER GOV CODE
ONE NINE THREE TO. PRIVATE RAY
PSYCHOTIC. AT UP TO TWO AND
SEVENTY FIVE DOLLARS AN HOUR
THAT'S TWICE THE SALARY OF OUR
CIVIL SERVICE PSYCHIATRIST AND
THAT DOESN'T EVEN INCLUDE THE
SIXTY FIVE DOLLARS AN HOUR
ADMINISTRATIVE FEE. SEVERAL OF
THESE CONTRACTORS HAVE PAID
OVER SEVENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS A
MONTH AND WHAT MADE EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN A MONTH
ACCORDING TO THE DATA SUPPLIED
BY THE STATE. CDCR AND DSHS
HEALTH CARE CONTRACTORS ACROSS
THE STATE UP TO A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
BESIDES THIS MONETARY WASTE
INTERMITTENT CONTRACTORS
PROVIDE LESS CONTINUITY OF CARE
CALIFORNIA'S INMATES AND
MENTALLY ILL. AND THIS IS IN
CONFLICT WITH THE EXPRESS GOAL.
OF THE POTTER AND COLEMAN COURT
ORDERS. ALSO CIVIL SERVICE
MORALE SUFFERS WHEN CONTRACTORS
ARE PRESENT. IMAGINE WORKING
ALONGSIDE SOMEONE WHO MAKES
TWICE AS MUCH AS YOU DO BUT
ENJOYS PREFERENTIAL WORK
SCHEDULES I KNOW MANDATORY ON
CALL DUTIES. NO WONDER THAT
MANY OF OUR DOCTORS HAVE QUIT
THEIR JOBS. TO BECOME
CONTRACTORS. BOB AS BEFORE
TWENTY TWO SIXTY AND CENTER OUR-
JUST TO STAY BY CREATING A
STATE REGISTRY WITH HIGHER PAY
SB SIX FIFTY SEVEN ACCESS A
COMPLIMENTARY BOOK AND BILL. BY
RESTRICTING OUR CONTRACTORS
TOTAL TIME THREE HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE DAYS IN THE STATE'S
POSITION. THAT AMOUNT OF TIME
SHOULD BE SUFFICIENT FOR A
DOCTOR TO DECIDE IF HE OR SHE
WANTS TO BECOME A STATE
EMPLOYEE. IN ADDITION THE BILL
PROVIDES CONFIDENTIALITY
TRANSPARENCY AND FLEXIBILITY TO
RENEW THE CONTRACTOR IF THE
AGENCY CAN SHOWN ACCEPTED. ONE
FURTHER THOUGHT ON WINNING THE
STATE OF THE TO DICTION THE
CONTRACTORS YOU A PRETTY IN THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD SERIOUSLY
CONSIDER AN AMENDMENT BUT NOT
ONLY RESTRICTS THE CONTRACTORS
TIME ON THE JOB. BUT ALSO THEIR
HOURLY RATE. THIS IS WORKED IN
THE PAST TO MAKE IT WORK AGAIN.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE
OPPOSITION UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION BY THE DENTAL HYGIENE
BORDER CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
WITHDRAWN. SO WE ASK
RESPECTFULLY PRETTIER AYE VOTE
ON A. B. SIX FIFTY SEVEN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. WITNESSED FIRST
SUPPORT DR BRIAN KIM PLEASE.
HEY BACK TO MINE CAME ON THE
SUPPORT OF COOPER A BEACH SIX
FIFTY SEVEN- PART OF THE BOARD
OF THE- AMERICAN THAT POSITION
IN DENTISTRY- THE REASON WHY
SUPPORT BILLS BECAUSE THIS KIND
OF. DECREASE BECAUSE- OF THE
HIRING- TRADITIONS AND
DENTISTRY IMPLANT PODIATRIC
INTO LAW OUR STATE SYSTEM WE
HAVE BEEN USING CONTRACTORS BY
THE RATE AT LIKE TALKED ABOUT
HE WAS TALKING ABOUT IT ON THE
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF CALL. AND
WE'RE SPENDING HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT WE
DON'T NEED TO SPEND TO OUR
CONTRACTOR FOR NOT VESTED IN
OUR STATE SERVICE BOB THE
STATE'S THE EMPLOYEES AFFECTED
IN OUR PATIENTS. AND PEOPLE IN
OUR STATE SO IT IS BEST TO HIRE
STATE SERVANTS FOR GOING GOING
TO DO A BETTER JOB INSTEAD OF
CONTRACTORS WERE JUST THERE FOR
ME A PAYCHECK. AND ALSO GIVING
THREE HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE DAYS
SHOULD BE ENOUGH FOR A
CONTRACTED TO DECIDE IF THE
STATE SERVICE IT'S THE RIGHT
THING FOR THEM- GIVING MORE
TIME TO YOU KNOW IT WAS NOT
GOING TO HELP- YOU KNOW THE
STATE AND THE STATE BUDGETARY
ESPECIALLY DURING THE COLD WAR
ERA. THE LAW SO MUCH UP FUNDING
AND MONEY- I THINK WE SHOULD
NOT BE WASTING OUR MONEY ON
CONTRACTORS AND ALSO LIKE I
SAID BEFORE- THE STATE'S UP-
STATE SERVANTS WILL BE A BETTER
EMPLOYEE A BETTER POSITION TO
OUR PATIENTS. IN OUR STATE
SYSTEM- THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THIS TIME. THANK YOU. ARE THEY
ARE A YOU STILL HOLDING THIS IS
IN HEARING. I- NO WITNESSES IN
THE VIDEO STATION. OPERATOR A
DO WE HAVE ANY. WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. OUR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION A. B. SIX FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AT THAT
ZERO THAT COMMAND AGAIN ONE
ZERO. AND WE DO HAVE ONE
COMMENT COMING THROUGH ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE PROVIDE
THEM AND THEY JUST DISCONNECTED
BUT WE HAVE NO COMMENT AT THE
TIME. THEN DO WE HAVE ANY
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT. OR COMMENT
IN SUPPORT OF AB. SIX FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO THAT COMMAND AGAIN. ONE
SEVEN ZERO. THERE IS A COMMENT
COMING THROUGH ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. ONE ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
FIVE YEAR MIKE IS THAT. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS COULD STOP MAYOR
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES
WE APPRECIATE THE CHART TOPPING
THE BILL AND WE ARE CLOSED DR
SB SIX FIFTY SEVEN. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IS THAT AN OPERATOR.
WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT
THIS TIME VERY WELL ABOVE THE
RECORD LET IT SHOW THAT THERE
ARE THERE IS NO ONE IN THE
WITNESS ROOM- IN OPPOSITION AND
NO ONE ON THE VIDEO SCREEN.
COMMENTS QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THERE ARE NONE TO
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND. I
HAVE. MOVED IN ABOUT THE WHOLE
WORLD. THE GUYS GO REALLY FAST
FOR ME. WE HAVE A MOTION WE
HAVE A SECOND PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION OF THE PASS
AND BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
COOPER HI COOPER HI VOEPEL HI
VOEPEL I CALDERON. CALDERON AYE
CERVANTES. COOLEY HI COOLEY I
O'DONNELL. O'DONNELL ICR. TWO
THAT THE BILL HAS VERY LITTLE
VOTES WILL PUT IT ON CALL THE
BILL'S UNCLE. THAT BRINGS US TO
A B. TEN FORTY EIGHT MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
VERSUS CURRENT LAW PREVENTS
FAMILY ENJOY HOSPITAL EMPLOYEES
FROM DURING THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT
ASSOCIATION. RETIREMENT
PLANNING EVERY OTHER ALAMEDA
HEALTH SYSTEMS EMPLOYEE HAS
ACCESS TO THIS CONSCRIPTION
PLAYS WITHIN THE HEALTH SYSTEM
TO SEE CAREER OPPORTUNITIES AT
SAN LEANDRO HOSPITAL BECAUSE
THEY WOULD LOSE THEIR ONGOING
BENEFITS. INCLUDING THEIR
RETIREMENT. THIS IS AN EQUITY
ISSUE THE AB TEN FORTY EIGHT
WILL RESOLVE BY ALLOWING THESE
PARTICULAR EMPLOYEES TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT
ASSOCIATION THIS IS A THREE
FOUR BILL THAT IS SUBJECT TO
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING PROCESS.
DOES NOT FORCE ANY PARTY
INVOLVED TO AGREE TO ANY
ADDITIONAL BENEFITS WAGES OR
WORKING CONDITIONS WITH ME
TODAY IN WITNESSES AND SUPPORT
I HAVE TERRY BRENNAN FROM SEIU
ALONG WITH NATO GREEN
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
COORDINATOR FOR SEIU. TEN
TWENTY ONE. VERY WELL. MR
ROBERT- PLEASE. WELL LET'S
START WITH IN PERSON NO NEED TO
TORTURE YOU MUCH LONGER. AND
THAT IS THIS IS BEEN A BREEZE
THIRTY NINE YEAH MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JERRY BROWN
AND ABOUT HALF VAST YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIA THIS IS A DISTRICT
BILLS THAT- THEN
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS BONTA WAS KIND
ENOUGH TO OFFER FOR US- WE
APPRECIATE THE- IF THE COOPER
STEPPING INTO PITCHING FOR US
ON THIS- AS I THINK WE'VE
WORKED WITH BOTH SIDES ARE NAY
AS THERE IS. CONFLICTING
PORTIONS OF THE ENABLING
LEGISLATION THAT THIS BILL
CLEARS UP AND IT DOESN'T
PROVIDE ANY BENEFITS ALLOWS IT
TO BE A SUBJECT NEGOTIATION AND
ALLOW. LISTEN TO WORK IN A
HOSPITAL THEY CURRENTLY CAN'T
WORK AND FOR THAT REASON WE ARE
TRY VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. OPERATOR LITTLE
GREEN. HELLO- THANK YOU THIS IS
MADE OF GREEN THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING COURT INTERPRETER
YOU LOCAL AND THE ONE- WELL I
WILL WORK WITH THE MEMBERS THAT
ALAMEDA HEALTH WITH THEM THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR SPONSORING-
THIS BILL AND HOLDING THIS
HEARING- WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT-
THE AFFAIR A PENSION PLAN HAS
SOMETHING LIKE TEN THOUSAND
MEMBERS AND POTENTIALLY THERE'S
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MEMBER OF THE FAMILY AT THE
HOSPITAL WORKLOAD FROM THE
PENSION PLAN AND NOT BOTH THE
INTERNAL INEQUITY THAT THEY
HAVE ACCESS TO. A WORK
RETIREMENT- BENEFITS- IN
ADDITION TO CREATE A BUNCH OF
OPERATE BENEFITS- BECAUSE OF
HOW THE ALAMEDA HEALTH SYSTEM
HAS INTEGRATED THEIR OPERATIONS
IN OTHER WAYS OVER THE YEARS.
YOU NOW LITERALLY HAVE A TABLET
THAT AREA WHERE. YOU HAVE
WORKERS IN THE THIRTEEN JOB
QUALIFICATIONS. ARE IF THEY
NEED YOUR HELP WITH THE PAIN OF
ALL YOUR- ONE ON THE SECOND
FLOOR AND ONE ON THE THIRD
FLOOR OF THE SAME BUILDING IN
DIFFERENT PENSION PLAN. AND YOU
CAN'T TRANSFER FROM THE SECOND
QUARTER BURKE FLOOR. WITHOUT
QUITTING AND BEING RE HIRE- IN
ORDER TO BECAUSE THE BECAUSE
THE BARRIER. OF THE PENSION
PLAN TO BUILD WE HAVE AN
AGREEMENT WITH THE EMPLOYER
THAT THE IF THE LEGISLATION
PASSES. WE WILL BE ABLE TO
NEGOTIATE AND- CAN COME UP WITH
A MUTUALLY BENEFICIAL
RESOLUTION THE- BILL ABBOTT
STANDARDIZED RETIREMENT
BENEFITS ACROSS THE GLOBE. AND
WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. OPERATOR
I- HOLD NO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION DO YOU CONCUR. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION TO A. B. TEN FORTY
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE AT THAT
ZERO THAT COMMAND AGAIN. ONE
SEVEN ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION VERY
WELL COMMENTS IN SUPPORT. OR
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF A. B. TEN
FORTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO THAT COMMAND AGAIN.
ONE SEVEN ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO
SUPPORT COMMENTS AT THE TIME.
AND I SEE NO OPPOSITION IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND NO OPPOSITION
ON THE VIDEO SCREEN. YEAH
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS CONCERNS.
THERE ARE NONE WE HAVE A MOTION
BY MISTER COOLEY A SECOND BY
ASSEMBLY WOMAN CALDERON. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS
THE PATH COOPER COOPER HI
VOEPEL HI VOEPEL I CALDERON.
CALDERON AYE CERVANTES. COOLEY
COOLEY AYE O'DONNELL O'DONNELL
I SAY ARE TO THE BILL HAS
FAVORED SO PUT IT ON CALL. HIS
UNCLE THANK YOU. AT THE- END OF.
SERGEENKO THE ABSENT MEMBERS
UNTIL WE THE ROLE FOR TEN
MINUTES. WE NEED TO BOTH THE
ROLE OF CATCH UP ON THE BODY.
YOU KNOW PARTY WITH. THE ITEM
NUMBER ONE E. B. NINETY FOUR
THE CURRENT VOTERS FORTY ZERO.
BUT THE CHAIR VOTING I.
O'DONNELL O'DONNELL I. THE BILL
HAS FIVE VOTES WILL PUT IT BACK
ON CALL. THANK YOU. NUMBER TWO
AB ONE OH FIVE THE CURRENT
VOTERS FORTY ZERO WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE O'DONNELL.
MADONNA I THAT HAS FIVE ZERO
PUT THAT ON CALL. THANK YOU.
YEAH. THIS. THE OKAY THANK YOU.
THEY ARE CURRENTLY. IT BOB.
THE
GRAPHICS CARE FIFTY THINKING.
OPEN OKAY MA'AM SECRETARY THIS
ITEM NUMBER ONE HE BEING NINETY
FOUR THE CURRENT VOTED FIVE TO
ZERO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
KNOW THEATER NOT VOTING. THAT
WILL BE PLACED BACK ON CALL. I
AM NUMBER TWO AB ONE OF FIVE
THE CURRENT RATE IS FIVE TWO
ZERO CHAIR VOTING I. ARE IT WAS
NEVER GOING FORWARD. THE BILL
CURRENTLY HAS FIVE VOTES
REPLACEMENT BERMAN CO. THE
SEATTLE FOR AB ONE OH FIVE NO.
NOW SHARES OF HARDING AND NO
THE BILL HAS. FIVE TO ONE OF
THOSE OLD. WHICH WHICH WAS THAT
AB ONE OH FIVE AB ONE OH FIVE
IS OUT ON A VOTE OF. THANKS FOR
THE ONE THANK YOU. I AM NUMBER
THREE AB NINETY THE CURRENT
VOTERS FIVE TO ONE. THE
CHAIRMAN ICR TELL. NOT VETTING
THAT BILL IS OUT ON A FIVE TO
ONE OKAY ON A. B. EIGHT NINETY
THAT'S BILLS OUT ON A VOTE OF
FIVE TO ONE. I AM NUMBER FOUR
EIGHTY SIX FIFTY SEVEN. CURRENT
THAT IS FIVE TWO ZERO. AFTER
READING HI. CERVANTES CERVANTES
ICR TONO FIGURE TO NOTE THAT
VOTE THAT BILL IS OUT ON A SIX
TO ONE. SB SIX FIVE SEVEN IS
OUT ON A VOTE OF SIX TO ONE.
ADAM NUMBER FIVE AB TEN FORTY
CURRENT THAT IS FIVE TWO ZERO.
WITH CHARITY I CERVANTES.
CERVANTES I THEATER. I FEAR
THAT ARE THE BILL IS OUT ON THE
SEVEN TWO ZERO. LEVELS UP THE
BIG TEN FORTY IS THAT A VOTE OF
SEVEN TO ZERO- THANK YOU WE'VE
GOT. RID ONE WE WHEN WE WANTED.
TO PROVIDE HIM NUMBER. ONE AB
NINETY FOUR. CURRENT VOTERS TO
ZERO SEVEN TO. CERVANTES AYE
THAT BUILD ATOMISTIC ZERO VOTE.
AB NINETY FOUR IS ON THE BOARD
OF SIXTY FOUR I'M SORRY SIX
FIVE ONE SIX ZERO SIX ZERO
THANK YOU. OKAY WITH THAT IT.
NUMBER FIVE WITH FIVE TO ONE
CERVANTES ROUTED I. ONE OH FIVE
SCHOOLS AND. YES THAT WILL
ASSEMBLY OKAY THAT BRINGS IT
INTO OUR GENDER EVERYONE HAVE A
GREAT WEEKEND.